nous voulons sauver l'humanité c'est
aussi ce que vous et votre pays
du lait 2
ce soit lui qui nous tue dis moi ce que
tu as vu
c'est ta vie
l'épidémie va si personne ne peut nous
sauver
sur helder transporté l'humanité sur une
autre planète 7 milliards de personnes
c'est impossible
on a besoin du web et même si on ne vous
fait pas confiance on en est on arrivé
il a besoin du garçon je ne le trouvera
jamais cet enfant est très spéciale du
doigt le temps et qu'il te tue
[Musique]
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui est
sur le point de se passer x-files
nouvelle saison inédite samedi à 21h sur
m6
[Musique]
juillet 1947 nouveau-mexique zone 51
malgré les témoins le secret demeure
mais la vérité est plus proche que
jamais
x-files nouvelle saison inédite samedi 7
avril sur m6 je suis comment cette
impasse
par l'enfer sur terre
[Musique]
x-files nouvelle saison inédite samedi 7
avril sur m6